so
for me the thing that i was really
fascinated by and always have been
is um people right and and how how
people work
yet when i looked out of the internet
right in 2004 which is when i was
getting started
you can find almost anything else that
you wanted right you could find news
movies music uh reference materials
but the thing that mattered the most to
people um which was other people and
like understanding what's going on with
them
it just wasn't there you know people
have this deep thirst to understand
what's going on with with those around
them
and um you know there were probably you
know 10 other things like that that i
built when i was at harvard
before i actually got around to to
building the first version of facebook
that kind of added a lot of these things
together
i built the first version of facebook
because it's something that
my friends and i wanted to use at
harvard a directory and a way to connect
with the other people
around us and i i didn't think at all
that it was going to be a company but we
just kind of followed what people wanted
and that
led us to expand it to all these other
schools and um
and eventually beyond schools and to you
know at some point
uh once we'd hired a bunch of people we
decided to turn it into a company and
and um and go for this mission of
connecting the world
a couple years in some big companies
wanted to buy us
i didn't want to sell i wanted to see if
we could connect more people
nearly everyone else wanted to sell
after one particularly tense argument
one of my close advisors told me if i
didn't agree to sell the company right
now
i would regret that decision for the
rest of my life
relationships were so afraid that within
a year or so
every single person on our management
team was gone
that was my hardest time leading
facebook
i believed in what we were doing but i
felt alone
and worse it was my fault
i wondered if i was just wrong an
imposter
a 22 year old kid who had no idea how
things actually worked
now years later i understand that that
is how things work when there's no sense
of higher purpose
so it's up to all of us to create it so
we can all keep moving forward
together
i'm here to tell you that finding your
purpose
isn't enough the challenge for our
generation
is to create a world where everyone has
a sense of purpose
purpose is that feeling that you
are a part of something bigger than
yourself
that you are needed and that you have
something better ahead to work for
purpose is what creates true happiness
i always think that the most important
thing that entrepreneurs should do is
pick something they care about
work on it but don't actually commit to
turning it into a company until it's
working
and i think that if you look at the data
of like the very best companies that
have gotten built
i actually think a tremendous percent of
them have been built that way
and not from people who decided up front
that they wanted to start a company
you know for anyone who's had the
experience of actually building a
company you know that you go through
some really hard things along the way
and
i think part of what gets you through
that is believing in what you're doing
and knowing that what you're doing is is
really
delivering a lot of value for people
and that's i think how the best
companies end up getting made
let me tell you a secret no one does
when they begin
ideas don't come out fully formed
they only become clear as you work on
them
you just have to get started
[Music]
if i had to know everything about
connecting people before i got started
i never would have built facebook
movies and pop culture just get this all
wrong
the idea of a single eureka moment is a
dangerous lie
it makes us feel inadequate because we
feel like we haven't had ours yet
and it prevents people with seeds of
good ideas from ever getting started in
the first place
you know my answer to that question is
don't even bother trying to avoid
mistakes because you're going to make
tons of mistakes
right and the the um the important thing
is actually learning quickly
from whatever mistakes you make and not
giving up right and
i mean there are things every single
year of facebook's existence that could
have killed us or made it so that
it just seemed like moving forward and
making a lot of progress just seemed
intractable
but you just kind of bounce back and you
learn and nothing is impossible you just
have to kind of
keep running through the walls
if you think about it you know i started
the company when i was 19 right so
i can't institutionally believe that
experience is that important
right or else i would have a hard time
reconciling um you know myself
right and and and the company so you
know we
invest in in people who we think are
just
really talented even if they haven't
done that thing before
and you know that applies to people who
are fresh out of university
as well as you know people like um you
know the cfo who took the company public
had not taken a company public before
right and
a lot of his background was in um you
know production uh development at
genentech before so
you know just focus on really talented
people
and we're focused on three things
connectivity right so getting everyone
in the world on the internet um so i
think connecting everyone is is really a
key thing
which is going to be be great for for
people around the world uh the next one
is ai i think that that's just gonna
unlock so much potential in so many
different domains
and you know we use it at facebook for a
lot of different things for
showing people content that they're
gonna find more meaningful for making
sure that you
connect with the people you actually
care about on the service and then
you know the next thing that i always
think is is going to make a big
difference
is um virtual reality and augmented
reality
um and that i think is just gonna help
people
you know be more creative um experience
what other people are feeling
much more immersively than than we even
can through um through video and things
like that today
so i'm really excited about that trend
as well
[Music]